[Music]
do
many of us who work with urban trees
feel that they have a real importance to
the health of our communities they
provide us with
shade wind reduction noise reduction
cleaning of the air and many other
benefits which really make our cities
livable
but for many cities the cost of placing
trees in cities is prohibitive and
it's generally not considered a priority
as a city forester i maintain the trees
which provide so many benefits to our
urban environment
trees really make our communities much
more desirable places to live
however
as a city employee i'm also acutely
aware of the expense in establishing and
maintaining city trees
it's these expenses which municipalities
constantly struggle with in trying to
create and maintain their urban forests
[Music]
in ithaca we've been working on a
project here at cornell where we're
trying to reduce the cost of planting
trees in cities and actually plant more
trees to benefit the urban environment
and the way we're doing that is a method
which is a very old method called bare
root transplanting
now bare root transplanting is taking a
tree out of the ground without soil
around its roots
one of the major advantages is that we
can plant many many more trees using a
bare root method because bare root trees
are on the whole cheaper
you don't need heavy machinery to plant
bare root trees
we can just pick them up
and walk down the street and plant them
so it's a major advantage for cities and
at a much reduced cost
the traditional method of planting trees
in urban areas is called bald and
burlapped b and b
where you have a large soil volume
around the root system those trees of
the size that we're planting weigh
anywhere from 100 to 300 pounds
[Music]
a bald and burlap tree
is traditionally dug
with a tree spade a machine that
takes off about 90 of the root system in
the process of digging that
ball of earth with the tree
[Music]
the tree then has to be put into a
burlap lined wire basket and that burlap
has to be fastened the wire basket has
to be fastened around the tree
[Music]
now you're upwards around several
hundred pounds and the cost of
moving and shipping that tree
rises quite steeply at that point
because there's tremendous weight in
that ball
[Music]
let's let's do the uh bnb tree first
let's see what it looks like and then we
can look at the barrow tree and see what
its root system is like and compare the
two
everything about these trees is the same
except that they've been dug differently
well the major advantages of using bare
root compared to b and b trees is that
we get up to 200 percent more root
with a bare root tree compared to a bald
and burlap tree
now the advantage of this should be
clear in that with a bigger root system
we have a much better opportunity to get
more water and nutrients into that newly
transplanted tree
with all the advantages of using bare
root trees there's one major
disadvantage
and that is the roots drying out because
we don't have soil around them
if they dry out the tree is worthless
we felt that we could
solve this problem by using a substance
called hydrogel
hydrogels are inert substances which
absorb up to 400 times their weight in
water
they're actually used in potting mixes
some people feel that works well or in
other industrial uses
we felt that using them for bare root
dipping would be really
advantageous if we could get the right
grind size and the right adherence
we thought that by
dipping the root system into a slurry of
hydrogel we could create a reservoir of
water around the roots keeping them
healthy for a length of time until they
could be transplanted into the ground
hydrogels in the nursery trade are used
in small tree transplanting or for
shipping so this was nothing new but
what we felt was worth pursuing was to
try to use these with big
municipal trees and this was very new so
one of the things we had to work out in
that process was the the grind size the
particle size if you like of hydrogel
because these particles actually swell
absorb water they don't dissolve
so the larger the particle size the
chunkier the piece of
jello looking hydrogel became
so a coarse grind would fall off the
root system
whereas a very fine grind would swell up
and adhere
really well to all those fine roots
which is what we wanted it to
do and that created a reservoir of water
keeping the roots moist and keeping the
tree healthy for at least a week or ten
days
when doing a large scale bare root tree
planting program
planning before the event is crucial
in ithaca a critical part of the success
of our bare root tree planting program
is the participation of volunteers
a centralized staging area needs to be
identified from which volunteers will be
coordinated
the volunteers need to be trained in
tree planting techniques and all this
has to be done well in advance of
picking the trees up
[Music]
the process of bare root transplanting
that we've devised really starts with
cooperation with a nursery
this is really important we work in
partnership with the nursery so that
when we go up to dip the trees the trees
will be out of the ground the shortest
period of time as possible preferably
less than 24 hours
municipalities have to plan to use bare
root trees they have to have an address
we have to know where they're going what
the soil type is and what the right
location will be
so all of that planning goes on before
we plant them
the city of ithaca has a computerized
tree inventory we've identified all the
planting sites in the city we measure
several parameters of that site and then
match a tree species to the site we make
out these tags before we come to the
nursery then place them on the tree here
so we already know where this particular
tree is going
we then get large vats ready with a
hydrogel dip which is basically adding
powdered hydrogel to water and mixing it
and very shortly it starts to thicken up
now what we're looking for is a
consistency something like thick gravy
[Music]
the barrow trees are immersed
in the hydrogel dip
[Music]
we really look for the consistency that
adheres to the roots and gives us that
good coverage that we're looking for
[Music]
the excess is allowed to drop off and
then the roots are put directly into
large pleated thick plastic bags which
will keep the trees in good shape with
the hydrogel for seven to ten days
don't
[Music]
the trees are then loaded onto a truck
kept cool old during this time
and
shipped back to the municipality and we
have up to a week to do the planting
we can get several hundred trees into a
truck which really makes it cost
effective from our point of view
[Music]
so
[Music]
one of the major advantages of using
bare root compared to b and b trees is
planting by volunteers
you don't need heavy machinery and a
large crew to do the transplanting
[Music]
a city such as ithaca might plant 30
bald and burlap trees in one day with a
crew and heavy machinery where we could
plant twice or three times as many
with a volunteer crew using shovels and
hands
you're really making a tremendous
savings that way not to mention making
everybody feel good about planting the
trees in their community
i've been working with the shade tree
advisory committee for the last seven or
eight years doing a lot of bare root
tree planting
when you use bare root trees instead of
ball and burlap planting it's a great
way for communities to save money and a
person even as small as myself can carry
a tree
and it's a great way as a volunteer in
planting trees to be able to give
something back to your community and you
can actually see the trees grow that you
planted
the first year is critical in
establishing urban trees
a couple of important steps that we take
are using drip irrigation bags and wood
chip mulch
the mulch keeps the ground from drying
out around the trees and probably more
importantly keeps lawnmowers and string
trimmers away
the drip irrigation bags put a measured
amount of water directly on the tree's
roots over an eight to forty eight hour
period
this provides for a deep soaking of the
root zone and better establishment of
urban trees
[Music]
in the city of ithaca we've been using
the bare root transplanting method now
for six years and have had great success
we feel really good about the thousand
trees we put on the streets many of
which are quite large now and really
making a change in our environment
the cost is less we use volunteers and
that really creates a sense of purpose
and camaraderie around our urban
vegetation
and the result is a much greener better
environment for all people who live in
the cities
[Music]
so
[Music]
you